after croatia which country will become
the 29th to join the european union is
enlargement even still on the agenda
five countries are currently in eu
membership negotiations
turkey the former yugoslav republic of
macedonia montenegro iceland and serbia
for a long time now it was thought
iceland would be the next country to
follow croatia in joining the euro club
but since 2013 doubt has been cast on
iceland's future accession
with a financial crisis the euro lost
its symbolic promise of a better feature
for icelanders hard hit by the crash
negotiations
um
serbia is also under the mep spotlight
today with eu membership talks with
belgrade set to start in january
progress towards the eu will depend on
serbia normalizing ties with kosovo but
that's not the only issue
state of law didn't function at all
organized crime and corruption was
spread all around the country corruption
is systemic that's why they need to
clean all these institutions serbia
leads the way ahead for balkan countries
the three other potential candidate
countries albania kosovo and bosnia and
herzegovina watching closely